That boy needs therapy. Lie down on the couch. Frontier Psychiatry. Well, we'll just go ahead and start where I can introduce you. So I'm here with J.F. Bear Lane. Am I saying that correctly? Close enough. Normally I kind of maybe over-prepare for these, but it's been such a crazy week. I've rescheduled three times and I don't have a ton of structure to the interview but i think the themes are going to be mythology
那孩子需要心理治疗。躺在沙发上。前沿精神病学。好吧，我们就从我介绍你开始吧。我和J.F. Bear Lane在一起。我读对了吗？差不多吧。通常我可能会为这些采访做过多的准备，但这周太疯狂了。我已经改期三次了，采访也没什么条理，但我认为主题会是神话。
and poetry um because you're a scholar and a poet and a gentleman anything else oh golly uh you're too generous uh i think it's really fun because I just want to give a little background. Joel was very kind when he contacted me. He said, you know, I read your books when I was a kid, which made me feel ancient, of course, and really enjoyed them. And it's so funny because I always spend time discussing my books saying, you know, I wrote them 30 years ago. And this is my OCD side where I say I found the following errors in them. And it's really funny because I got some contact back from people saying, you know, great book, but this was wrong.
和诗歌，嗯，因为你是一位学者、诗人，也是一位绅士，还有别的吗？哦，天哪，你太慷慨了。我觉得这真的很有趣，因为我只是想提供一点背景。Joel联系我时非常客气。他说，你知道，我小时候读过你的书，这当然让我觉得自己老了，而且真的很喜欢它们。这很有趣，因为我总是花时间讨论我的书，说，你知道，我30年前写的。这是我的强迫症一面，我会说我在书中发现了以下错误。这真的很有趣，因为我收到了一些人的反馈，说，书很棒，但这地方错了。
And I would write back and say, you're absolutely right. And the three examples I give are I was all excited because the city of mars pennsylvania it's named after the roman god no you've never a man named mars uh maybe he was named after the roman god yeah it might be and then the other one i thought was pretty funny was london the city of london i don't know where i got this from oh it was named after these the celtic god luke and about eight people said all from britain of course said where did you get that crazy idea that was another one it's londonium isn't it isn't it yeah but but yes and then the third one which is what the one i i blush when i admit to is hetero in greek of, right? But hetaira means a courtesan.
我会回信说，你说得完全对。我举的三个例子是，我当时很兴奋，因为宾夕法尼亚州的马尔斯市是以罗马神命名的，不，你从来没有一个叫马尔斯的人，也许他是以罗马神命名的，是的，可能是这样。另一个我觉得很有趣的是伦敦，伦敦市，我不知道我是从哪儿弄来的，哦，它是以凯尔特神卢格命名的，大约有八个人说，当然都是来自英国的，说你从哪儿得到那个疯狂的想法？那是另一个，是伦底纽姆，不是吗？是的，但第三个让我承认时脸红的是希腊语中的“hetaira”，对吧？但“hetaira”指的是交际花。
And so hetairism, I had read it in a different way. And what it was saying was the period of hetairism was, believe, the period of life analogous to the courtesans. And I missed that completely. It went right past my vision. But I cannot start an interview without, you know, confessing those three mistakes and somebody else, well, if you feel that way, then the rest of your book must be pretty good. And I said, well, I hope so. You know, I think, you know, it's always normal to make mistakes when you're compiling anything that's the
所以关于“hetairism”，我以不同的方式读过它。它所说的是，“hetairism”时期，我相信，是类似于交际花的生活时期。我完全错过了。它从我的视野中溜走了。但我不能不承认那三个错误就开始采访，有人说，好吧，如果你这么觉得，那么你书的其余部分一定很不错。我说，好吧，我希望如此。你知道，我认为，在编写任何像书一样大的东西时，犯错总是正常的，
size of a book, but also, you know it's going to be in anything. But I think what made your books better is that they're not strictly academic. They're about very intelligent concepts, but they're not pretentious. And there isn't that not not even pretension, but there's an academic type of writing where you can tell that someone is used to somebody behind them being like, oh, you didn't cite your source. How do you know that emotion comes from, you know, like're like okay just sit with the metaphor for a minute man like i'm not trying you know and then you can tell that there's some people that when they're writing they're trying to qualify everything and lay out these terms and define what the terms mean and explain why they're there before they tell it say anything and it makes the books kind of a miserable read
而且，你知道它会出现在任何东西里。但我认为让你的书变得更好的是它们并不完全是学术性的。它们涉及非常聪明的概念，但并不自命不凡。甚至不是自命不凡，而是一种学术写作，你可以看出有人习惯于背后有人说，哦，你没引用来源。你怎么知道那种情绪来自哪里，你知道，就像是，好吧，就让隐喻停留一会儿吧，伙计，我不是在尝试，你知道，然后你可以看出有些人写作时试图限定一切，列出这些术语并定义术语的含义，在说任何话之前解释它们为什么在那里，这让书读起来很痛苦。
you know like academic writing has its purpose but the purpose is research it's it's not well you know it's funny you should say that because i all of my all of the myths i cite in my books i always have you know references in the back of the book so if someone wants to know they can look but what i've found most useful is and this is a result of exactly what you're talking about reading works saying you know a lot of people i talk to say will you just tell me what the heck this myth is says what is the story here what is the narrative and you know i found that that people got more out of it and then what's really interesting is they ask more important questions and by important questions i mean not just about the meaning of the myth but how the myth informs their sense of meaning.
你知道，学术写作有它的目的，但目的是研究，它不是……好吧，你知道，你说得很有趣，因为我引用的所有神话，我书的后面总是有参考资料，所以如果有人想知道，他们可以查阅，但我发现最有用的是，这正是你所说的阅读作品的结果，说，你知道，我交谈的许多人说，你能不能告诉我这到底是什么神话，故事是什么，叙事是什么，你知道，我发现人们从中得到了更多，然后真正有趣的是，他们问了更重要的问题，我所说的重要问题，不仅仅是关于神话的意义，而是神话如何影响他们的意义感。
And that, I thought, was a much better approach than being too dry and academic. Because that's kind of where I was trying to take people. You know that from reading my books. to contemplate and uh what was it the uh chinese philosopher moses used to say that you know you can't learn anything without self-reflection well when you read a myth it's got to be like how does this affect me what is its sense on my meaning and i that's kind of where i was coming from so well i i plagiarized some of it i think in like sixth grade uh for a sermon because it was like a youth sunday or whatever and you had to give the sermon at the Episcopal Church. And I was doing something about sitting in the imagery of the Bible or sitting in the imagery of the story.
而且，我认为这比过于枯燥和学术化要好得多。因为这就是我试图引导人们的方向。你知道，从读我的书就能看出来。去沉思，嗯，中国哲学家墨子曾经说过，你知道，没有自我反思就学不到任何东西，当你读一个神话时，它必须是，这对我有什么影响？它对我的意义感有什么影响？我就是从那里出发的，所以，好吧，我在六年级的时候抄袭了一些，为了一个布道，因为那是青年主日什么的，你必须在圣公会教堂做布道。我当时在做关于坐在圣经意象中或坐在故事意象中的事情。
And you had a chapter about water and water showing up in myths and all these facts about water. And I remember copying and pasting a lot of lines from that into the sermon. So your words have come from the pulpit, too. Well, the statute of limitations is out, so I'm not going to bother you. I didn't make any money off the sermon. No, there you go. That's the whole thing. But it's pretty funny, though, when I hear people have quoted me and so on.
你有一章是关于水和出现在神话中的水，以及所有关于水的事实。我记得把其中的很多行复制粘贴到了布道中。所以你的话也来自讲坛。好吧，诉讼时效已过，所以我不会打扰你。我没从布道中赚到钱。不，就是这样。这就是全部。但当我听到人们引用我等等时，这很有趣。
A couple of really funny things, before I get into some of my later work and what I've been doing, a couple of great funny stories to tell is I'm more popular in Brazil than I mean the United States and I find this totally funny because they sold the Portuguese rights and I speak and read Portuguese so I got to read the manuscript which is pretty cool and make my little you know notes and so on. And I started getting calls for interviews with outlets in Brazil. And what was funny was, and they knew I spoke Portuguese, so it was really funny. And at one point, I think it was, my sales in Brazil were higher than they were in the United States and Canada.
在进入我后来的工作和我一直在做的事情之前，有几件非常有趣的事情，有几个很棒的有趣故事要讲，我在巴西比在美国更受欢迎，我觉得这完全很有趣，因为他们卖了葡萄牙语版权，而我会说和读葡萄牙语，所以我读了手稿，这很酷，并做了我的小笔记等等。我开始接到巴西媒体的采访电话。有趣的是，他们知道我会说葡萄牙语，所以这真的很有趣。有一次，我想，我在巴西的销量比在美国和加拿大还要高。
It happens. It happens. You hit the Z-ge to some other country like Japan. A lot of times something will blow up there, you know, 10 years later or something. I think it's Brazil. It's some South American country, but there was this show that was like on APT,
这会发生的。这会发生的。你击中了像日本这样的国家的时代精神。很多时候，某样东西会在那里火起来，你知道，10年后什么的。我认为是巴西。是某个南美国家，但有一个节目在APT上，
just Alabama public television when I was a kid. And it was like a weirder version of Bill Nye, the science guy. It's called Beekman's world. So there'd be a guy that was like an Iraq costume and they would would do science experiments it was like real wacky so for some reason that is still you know no one even remembers it here for some reason it's like huge in this South American country it's like still on tv being rerun and the guy like went to live there because he's basically a celebrity but it's a show to teach kids science. It's weird, but it spoke to something in the culture.
当我还是个孩子的时候，只是阿拉巴马公共电视台。它就像是《比尔教科学》的一个更奇怪的版本。它叫《比克曼的世界》。所以会有一个穿着伊拉克服装的人，他们会做科学实验，这真的很古怪，所以出于某种原因，这里甚至没人记得它，出于某种原因，它在那个南美国家非常火，它还在电视上重播，那个人甚至去那里住了，因为他基本上是个名人，但这是一个教孩子科学的节目。这很奇怪，但它触及了文化中的某些东西。
Oh, very strange. I love stuff like that. That is fun. But yeah, go ahead, sir, please. Well, I guess just so for the listeners to introduce you, we've been wanting to talk for a while, so probably want to qualify so other people can understand the conversation. I'm a therapist now, and I write a lot about myth and psychology and the fusion of those things
哦，非常奇怪。我喜欢那样的东西。那很有趣。但是的，请继续，先生。好吧，我想只是为了让听众介绍你，我们已经想谈很久了，所以可能想限定一下，以便其他人能理解对话。我现在是一名治疗师，我写了很多关于神话、心理学以及这些东西的融合，
and religion and young and um a lot of that i think you know i was born in 87 but i think it was still in the water from the 70s the joseph campbell stuff and um i so i read a lot of like science fiction and fantasy but i didn't really read a lot of nonfiction. And then he was in fifth or sixth grade, and a friend of our family gave me a gift certificate to the bookstore. So I went and picked your book out because I opened it to the story of the Hindu pantheon. I don't have the book on me, but somebody goes to talk to the god God and he's like, how many gods are there? And they're like, well, there's 130. And he's like, yeah, but really, how many are they?
还有宗教和荣格，嗯，我想你知道，我出生于87年，但我认为70年代的东西还在水里，约瑟夫·坎贝尔的东西，嗯，所以我读了很多科幻和奇幻，但我并没有真正读很多非虚构作品。然后他在五年级或六年级时，我们家的一位朋友给了我一张书店的礼券。所以我去选了你的书，因为我翻到了印度教万神殿的故事。我身上没带那本书，但有人去和神交谈，他说，有多少个神？他们说，嗯，有130个。他说，是的，但真的，有多少个？
And they're like, well, they share an aspect. There's really 50. And he's like, no, but really, how many are there? And he's like, well, there's three. He's like, well, how many are there? And it's like, okay, fine, you got me. It's really, I'm in all of them. Like, there's really just one, you know?
他们说，嗯，他们共享一个方面。真的有50个。他说，不，但真的，有多少个？他们说，嗯，有三个。他说，嗯，有多少个？就像是，好吧，好吧，你抓到我了。真的，我在他们所有人里面。就像，真的只有一个，你知道吗？
And it was like, and I started thinking about the way that religion, there's a universalness to it, but then there's also something that's very culturally unique. And then it's this people are talking about basically their life and their existence in a unique voice, but they're all describing the same thing, even though I don't really like the comparative religion trope that all religions are the same. I don't think that's true. And it was like, just open this door like what comparative religion was and all this stuff and i started getting into that and i read about mythology and all these things forever and people would always be like well joel likes history so he's reading these stories and it's like it's not history it's psychology you know like um and but it was no one really got that and it really opened a door. So it's exciting to talk to you now and see.
就像，我开始思考宗教的方式，它有一种普遍性，但也有一些非常独特的文化特征。然后是这些人基本上在用独特的声音谈论他们的生活和存在，但他们都在描述同一件事，尽管我不太喜欢所有宗教都是一样的比较宗教比喻。我不认为那是真的。就像，打开了这扇门，什么是比较宗教，所有这些东西，我开始接触那个，我永远都在读关于神话和所有这些东西，人们总是会说，嗯，乔尔喜欢历史，所以他在读这些故事，就像，这不是历史，这是心理学，你知道，嗯，但没人真正明白这一点，它真的打开了一扇门。所以现在和你谈话并看到这一点很令人兴奋。
So what brought you to wanting to write about mythology and doing those books? We have them in our professional library at work, and we let patients and clinicians borrow them. I tried to grab both of them, and they were both checked out. So hopefully we'll get them back. Well, that's a great introduction uh i i've always been a person who loved to read stories i was kind of a i guess you'd say introverted introspective kid and i remember one time my parents uh i think they wanted to shut me up so they said let's give this kid a book and leave'll leave us alone.
那么是什么让你想要写关于神话并写那些书的呢？我们在工作中的专业图书馆里有它们，我们让病人和临床医生借阅。我试着两本都拿，但都被借走了。所以希望我们能拿回来。好吧，这是一个很好的介绍，嗯，我一直是一个喜欢读故事的人，我猜你会说是一个内向、内省的孩子，我记得有一次我的父母，嗯，我想他们想让我闭嘴，所以他们说，给这孩子一本书，让他别打扰我们。
And the book was a mythology book. And I got into it. And that's probably about, I would say, 10 or 11. And it was a mythology for children. And it was Greek and Roman mythology and some Norse. And then I said, this is really good stuff. My grandparents then said, oh, that's, my grandparents said, oh, this is the birth
那本书是一本神话书。我迷上了它。那大概是，我会说，10岁或11岁。那是一本儿童神话书。那是希腊和罗马神话以及一些北欧神话。然后我说，这是真正的好东西。我的祖父母然后说，哦，那是，我的祖父母说，哦，这是这个孩子智力体验的诞生。
of an intellectual experience for this child. So they decided that they would bestune me with books, which all which I read. And then when I was in college and taking a course, I had a wonderful professor and this guy and I, I'll give a shout out to the late Theodore Ludwig. And this guy and I could talk for hours about mythology. And he was a fascinating guy.
所以他们决定用书来装点我，我全都读了。然后当我在大学上课时，我有一位很棒的教授，这个人，我要向已故的西奥多·路德维希致敬。我和这个人可以谈论神话几个小时。他是一个迷人的人。
He was a Lutheran pastor and a theologian and a scholar of mythology and all these things. And he said, you know what you need to do? You need to go, you need to get a copy of The Golden Bough by Fraser. And go sit on the beach sometime this I did that. And then it was the whole obsession I had with what are the common things that make us tick? All human beings have stuff that make them tick. And mythology kind of is a record of that search for meaning and what makes us tick and a reflection of it at the same time that makes some sense and so i thought that was really interesting and so i just continued to read and everything else in my my addiction to languages and also helped me out
他是一位路德教会牧师、神学家和神话学者，以及所有这些东西。他说，你知道你需要做什么吗？你需要去，你需要弄一本弗雷泽的《金枝》。去海滩上坐坐，有一次我做了。然后就是我对比我们有什么共同点的痴迷？所有人类都有让他们运转的东西。神话某种程度上是那种对意义的追求以及是什么让我们运转的记录，同时也是它的反映，这说得通，所以我认为这真的很有趣，所以我只是继续阅读，我对他人的语言的沉迷也帮助了我，
because i was able to then look at some you know even some primary sources with three dictionaries and a magnifying glass so you don't think i'm that clever uh how many languages do you speak you were speaking like in three or four different languages when we're on the phone telling a story about going to south america oh but how many languages are you fluent in enough uh you know i'm picking up english pretty well uh but actually my latest thing is i'm is turkish i really enjoy it it's not in new york and we've made three trips to turkey i have i'm going to give a shout out to my wonderful turkish teacher in istanbul seda surel and uh and you know you can watch all those great turkish soap operas understand them now without subtitles which
因为我能够用三本字典和一个放大镜看一些，你知道，甚至是一些原始资料，所以你别以为我那么聪明，嗯，你会说几种语言？我们在电话里讲去南美洲的故事时，你说了三四种不同的语言，哦，但你精通多少种语言？嗯，你知道，我英语学得还不错，但实际上我最近的东西是土耳其语，我真的很喜欢它，它不在纽约，我们去过土耳其三次，我要向我在伊斯坦布尔的精彩土耳其语老师Seda Surel致敬，嗯，而且你知道，你可以看所有那些伟大的土耳其肥皂剧，现在不用字幕就能听懂，这
which is great and by the way i want to talk about archetypes okay i'm going to tell you why i know an archetype is i will use turkish drama as a way to explain what archetypes are every turkish drama has the kindly and innocent uh young lady who is being abused by a wrathful father and or mother then there's always the sweet old lady who's the cleaning woman but knows all of their dirty secrets and then there's always the dashing but poor young man who's the hero there's always some vile vile rich spoiled brat kid and his rotten parents and disney movie oh it's it is it's like you know hallmark uh all that stuff well it's so funny as if you know someone were to ask me what is an archetype i'd say watch a turkish drama or actually probably any soap opera and you find
这很棒，顺便说一句，我想谈谈原型，好吧，我要告诉你为什么我知道什么是原型，我会用土耳其戏剧作为解释什么是原型的方式，每部土耳其戏剧都有善良和天真的年轻女士，被愤怒的父亲和/或母亲虐待，然后总有一个甜美的老太太，她是清洁工，但知道他们所有的肮脏秘密，然后总有一个潇洒但贫穷的年轻人，他是英雄，总有一些卑鄙、卑鄙、富有、被宠坏的顽童和他的烂父母，迪士尼电影，哦，它就是，就像你知道，霍尔马克，所有那些东西，好吧，这太有趣了，如果有人问我什么是原型，我会说看一部土耳其戏剧，或者实际上可能是任何肥皂剧，你会发现
the same type of characters and i said really that is what goes on in myth you've got very much this these archetypes and where do they come from well jung tells us that their image is in our collective unconscious uh but it's they occur everywhere they're fascinating because they occur in every culture and that was another thing that fascinated me in reading the myths that they you know some of the plots even i get one of one of my books I say there's a Blackfoot American Indian story that matches to an Egyptian story I mean that match the Bible story but the Bible story if the story yeah they were neighbors right but Blackfoot are out in the middle of the North America and it's just all of the material is there and levy Strauss and structural, they love that stuff.
同样类型的角色，我说真的，这就是神话中发生的事情，你非常有这些原型，它们来自哪里？嗯，荣格告诉我们，它们的形象在我们集体潜意识中，但它们到处出现，它们很迷人，因为它们出现在每种文化中，这也是我在读神话时让我着迷的另一件事，它们，你知道，甚至有些情节，我得到我的一本书，我说有一个黑脚印第安人的故事与一个埃及故事相匹配，我的意思是与圣经故事相匹配，但圣经故事，如果故事，是的，他们是邻居，对吧？但黑脚印第安人在北美中部，所有的材料都在那里，列维-斯特劳斯和结构主义，他们喜欢那些东西。
But I always felt that it's a sense of meaning is what that's about. That we all, human beings, you know, we're in this time now where people are all tribal. And they don't necessarily... They're still fighting about myths. You know, they're fighting about mythology. They don't share myths. They have common myths. And they don't see the commonality of other
但我总是觉得这关乎意义感。我们所有人，人类，你知道，我们现在处于一个人们都部落化的时代。他们不一定……他们还在为神话而战。你知道，他们在为神话而战。他们不分享神话。他们有共同的神话。他们看不到其他人的神话的共同点或其他人的共同点，你知道，这造成了冲突和所有这些东西，我当然，你知道，正如你所做的那样，我们试图减少他人的痛苦，试图让人们的生活变得更好一点，我认为这是你可以通过研究神话做到的事情之一，你开始说，啊，我有文化差异，但让我运转的东西和这个世界上其他每个人都很像，那将改变我看待和对待他人的方式，好吧，这很有趣，做一个植根于大脑医学和深度心理学的播客，就像荣格，深度心理学中的荣格东西，它影响了一切，所以我们和音乐家、建筑师和城市规划师谈过，一个人在我们城市规划纪录片之后联系了我们，或者在我们与安德烈·斯特拉尼的城市规划采访之后，有人发给了我他们的手稿，现在正在出版，我为他感到骄傲，也许有一天他会来这里，但他写了一本书，关于使用荣格和神秘主义来进行城市规划，比如如何找到人们想要与设计空间互动的方式的原型。荣格主义中有很多东西只是日常生活。你只是说，啊哈，就是这样。我不会进行长篇讨论，但我的意思是，有原型主义，也有阿尼玛斯、阿尼玛、阴影，所有这些东西你都看到体现出来，而且你比我更确定，但你看到它到处体现出来，它们某种程度上帮助你导航
people's myths or the commonality of other people and you know this creates strife and all stuff and i of course you know as as you do we try to lessen others suffering and try to make life a little better for people and that's one of the things i think you can do through the study of myth is you start saying ah i am i have cultural differences but the me what makes me tick is a lot like every other person out there in this world and that will change how i view and treat other people well it's interesting with the the doing a podcast that's kind of rooted in brain-based medicine and depth psychology is like union the union stuff in the depth psychology like it informs everything so it's we've talked to musicians and architects and urban planners a guy reached out after our urban planner documentary and he was like or after our urban
一点点，我觉得这是一个让你以一种更温柔的方式理解自己和他人的镜头，我想？你可以更好地驾驭生活。是的。用那种我认为一切都归结为的意义感来驾驭。所以你从小就开始读神话。你有没有接触过心理学，还是你一直留在数学领域？你的学术或你的轨迹作为专业人士是什么样的？我不会真正深入探讨它。你不想深入探讨它？
planning interview with andre strani somebody sent me their manuscript that now is getting published which is i'm proud of him maybe he'll be on here one day, but he had written a book about using Jung and mysticism to do urban planning, like how to find the archetypes of the way that people want to interact with a design space. There's a lot of things in Jungianism that are just everyday life. You just say, aha, that's it. I'm not going to get into a long discussion but i mean there's archetypalism but also animus anima the shadow all these things you see manifested and and you more than i'm sure but you see it manifested all over the place and they kind of help you navigate a
我不会真正深入探讨它，因为我现在在一家咨询公司工作。我们管理公司与联邦政府会面的合同，但它进入了政治学和经济学。我曾在美利坚大学的华盛顿学期项目中担任兼职教师。我过去常告诉人们，我的夜间工作是神话，我读过并做了很多事情。我有几个真正的学者，我并没有声称自己是，在这个领域联系过我。他们说，我们喜欢你的书，或者我们对你的想法感兴趣，等等。我说，好吧，我要告诉你，我没有自命不凡
little bit i feel it's a lens that lets you understand yourself and other people in a way that is gentler, I think? And you can navigate life better. Yeah. Navigate with that sense of meaning that I think everything boils down to. So you started reading mythology as a kid. Did you ever get into psychology or you stayed in math? What did your academic or what did your track look like as a professional? I won't really go into it. You don't want to go into it?
成为，你知道，这个话题的伟大深奥学者，我宁愿说我是一个非常非常感兴趣的业余爱好者，我是一个非常情绪化地参与神话的读者，我交谈过的人之一，实际上是一位大学的宗教系主任，对我说，是的，但你知道你在说什么。这很有趣。它让我的一天变得很美好。所以，是的，这就是我的轨迹。我的轨迹不是通常的那种。
I won't really go into it too much because now I'm working in a consulting firm. We manage contracts for companies to visit with the federal government, but it went into political science and economics. I was teaching as an adjunct in the Washington semester program at American University. And I used to tell people my night job was mythology, that I read and did so many things. And I've had a couple of people who are true scholars, which I didn't claim to be, in the field contact me. And they said, we like your book or we're interested in your ideas, so on. I said, well, I'm going to tell you I I don't have pretension to
至于心理学，我不认为你可以在不每一步都撞上心理学的情况下研究神话。我认为这很好。在意义感方面，我，你知道，你听到我一遍又一遍地说，我认为人类拥有意义感并驾驭他们的生活方式非常重要，我认为这是，而且我认为很多曾经给我们意义感和希望的东西正在世界上消失，你知道，即使是年轻一代，你知道，有民意调查，他们甚至不认为地球会
be you know this a great deep scholar of the topic I would say rather I'm a really really interested amateur I'm a really very uh emotionally engaged reader of mythology and one of the people I talked to uh actually was a chair of religions at a university, said to me, yeah, but you know what you're talking about. That was pretty funny. It kind of made my day. So, yeah, that was my trajectory. My trajectory wasn't the usual.
以它现在的能力存在于他们的孩子身上，或者经济系统会让他们的孩子拥有像我们这样的任何生活，并不是说这是真的还是假的，你知道，但那是一种信仰，你知道，和iPhone一起长大的人，你知道，在他们13岁之前，他们就已经在处理这种相当黑暗的存在主义东西了，当你在治疗中看到这一点时，就像代际差异过去是10年，现在就像当我看到一个25岁的人和一个19岁的人时，差异是巨大的，你知道，他们看待世界的方式。好吧，我同意你的观点。而且我也觉得所有这些，你知道，对僵尸之类的世界末日东西的迷恋非常迷人。
And as far as psychology goes, I don't think you can study mythology without bumping against psychology every step of the way. I think that's good. in the sense of meaning i i'm you know you hear me say it over and over again i think that so much is important about human beings having a sense of meaning and navigating their ways through life i think that's and i think a lot of things that used to give us a sense of meaning and hope are going away in the world you know even the younger generations you know there's polls and they don't even think the planet will be
而且，你知道，我进行过对话，非常聪明、理性的人说，你知道，僵尸末日很奇怪，而且可能非常明显是虚构的，但那种世界末日的东西并不那么疯狂。他们真的那么想。然后当COVID出现时，我记得很多人，特别是年轻人，对我说，好吧，你知道，这是生活模仿艺术。我们有所有这些像《爆发》之类的电影，所有这些东西。而且，我们现在就在这里。而且，你知道，生活模仿艺术，我们有所有这些像《爆发》之类的电影，所有这些东西，而且我们现在就在这里，而且你知道，会有那整整一年就像
around for their kids in the same capacity that it is now or that the econ the economic system will allow them to have any their kids to have any kind of semblance of life like we have and not saying that's true or false you know but that that's a belief you know people who grew up with an iphone you know think before they're you know 13 they are already sitting with this pretty dark existential stuff and when you see that in therapy it's like the generational difference used to be 10 years apart now it's like when i see somebody 25 and somebody 19, the difference is vast, you know, the way that they see the world. Well, I agree with you. And I also find fascinating all this, you know, the fascination with apocalyptic stuff like zombie stuff and all that.
你知道政治灾难、瘟疫和火灾，是的，我知道，当你知道硫磺和食物饥荒时，就像圣经一样，是的，那是我的公司，蝗虫什么时候出现，你知道，但是的，但我的意思是，你谈论的，我仍然是一个乐观主义者，但我老了，你知道，但我也认为，你知道，当你变老时，有一件事是，你经历过太多的火车失事，以至于你说我不会太担心这个，但，嗯，好吧，我认为这是事情可能不可持续的组合，在某个时候会发生变化。孩子们只是有获取信息的途径，他们能够在六岁时问谷歌那个问题。
And, you know, and I've had conversations, very intelligent, rational people said, you know, zombie apocalypse is strange and probably is very obviously fiction, but that type of apocalyptic thing is not so crazy. And they really think that. And then when COVID came out, I remember a number of people, younger people, especially saying to me, well, you know, this is life imitating art. We've had all these movies like outbreak and all this stuff. And, and here we are with this. And, you know, is life imitating art we've had all these movies like outbreak and all this stuff and and here we are with this and you know is there going that whole year was like
而大多数人到了大学才说，哦，如果什么都没有意义怎么办？你知道，那是他们第一次遇到每一年。任何事情，你知道，在他们20多岁时。而现在孩子们在五岁时就在处理那些东西，这可能剥夺了其他人享受的无知之乐，我只是说，当你和一个听起来像叔本华的七岁孩子交谈时，那是非常非常清醒的。好吧，所以你，你有没有研究过荣格或做过任何荣格心理学，还是你只是对神话感兴趣？以上所有，实际上。
you know political catastrophe and plague and fires and yeah i know when you know brimstone and food famine like it was just like the biblical yeah that was my company always when did the locusts show up you know but yeah but i mean what you talked i'm still an optimist but i'm old you know but i also think that you know one thing when you get old is you you've survived so many train wrecks that you say i wouldn't worry about this too much but uh well i think it's a combination of things are probably not sustainable there is going to be a change at some point. And kids just have access to information where they were able to ask that question at six to Google.
以上所有。多产的读者先生。是的。好吧，还有一件事，我实际上有一群朋友有一个荣格读书小组。这几乎是40年前的事了。那真的很有趣。而且我读德语，所以我读荣格的另一个原因，而且不像弗洛伊德，荣格在德语中是可读的，嗯，弗洛伊德，弗洛伊德让我读的时候大脑很痛
Whereas most people get to college and they're like, oh, what if nothing means anything? You know, that's the first time they encounter each year. Anything is, you know, in their 20s. And now kids are sitting with that stuff at five which is probably deprived of the uh pleasure of ignorance that others have enjoyed and i just say when you talk to a seven-year-old who sounds like schopenhauer that's very very sobering well so you you just did you um ever study young or do any union psychology or were you just kind of interested in myth? All of the above, actually.
试着读他的德语，但我可以很容易地读完荣格，而且这很有趣，因为我喜欢他讨论他的旅行，比如他在美国印第安人中的旅行，并描述他与他们的经历等等，以及他们的神话如何影响他们的意义感以及他们如何驾驭生活。而且我认为这是我仍然痴迷的东西。我的诗歌也反映了这一点。但我总是
All of the above. Mr. Prolific Reader. Yes. Well, also, the other thing, too, is I actually had a group of friends who had a Jungian reading group. And this is almost 40 years ago. And that was really interesting. And I read German, so I was another reason to read Jung and and unlike Freud Jung is readable in German uh Freud Freud hurts my brain when I read
觉得生活已经够艰难了。我相信你也有同样的感觉。如果你能以某种方式帮助人们驾驭生活，你就是在让自己的生活变得有意义。我喜欢我现在的工作，只是能够坐下来
try reading him in German but Jung I can get through pretty easily and and it's interesting because I like when he discusses his trips, like his trips among the American Indians and describes his experiences with them and so forth and how their mythology informs their sense of meaning and how they navigate through life. And I think that that's something that I'm still obsessed with. And my poetry reflects that as well. But I always
和病人在一起。我不喜欢商业部分，这是一种手段，只是为了确保其他人可以工作，我们可以建立一个诊所，但我不是为了那个而活，我为了只是和人们坐在一个房间里，嗯，帮助他们创造意义，即使你无法创造意义。是的，那是真的，工作总是打断我的园艺、诗歌写作，这真是一种耻辱，还有酿酒。我没有被打断，你知道。你酿酒？是的，当然。我得做那个。这对你有好处。
feel like life is hard enough. I'm sure you feel the same way. If you can somehow help people navigate through life, you're making your own life meaningful. I love the job that I have now, just being able to sit
我们住在德克萨斯州，我们有葡萄。我的意思是，有什么错，你知道，这都是好东西。所以，是的，我的意思是，但确实如此。我一直觉得我们能做的最有用的事情就是帮助其他人驾驭生活。这就是，我猜，我会这样说。而神话就是为了帮助人们驾驭生活而建立的。我的意思是，我的第二本书。这是一种创造意义的尝试。是的。
with patients. I don't like the business part is kind of a means to an end, just to make sure other people can work and we can build a clinic but i don't live for that i live for just sitting in a room with people and um helping them make meaning even when you can't make meaning yeah that's true and work always interrupted my gardening poetry writing it's just a shame and win winemaking. I was not interrupted, you know. You make wine? Yeah, of course. And I got to do that. That's good for you.
我的第二本书，《活的神话》，就像你生命的每个阶段都有一个神话，有一个某种文化或多种文化的神话，帮助你驾驭你生命中的那个阶段。我知道你读过它们，但只是为了听众，以防有人不熟悉，米尔恰·伊利亚德的《神圣与世俗》，这是一本关于宗教和神话研究的相当早期的书。他做的一件事是，他会找到这些土著部落，他们有一根棍子，部落的整个历史都写在棍子上。而棍子是你帐篷的帐篷杆。
We live in Texas and we have grapes. I mean, what's wrong with, you know, it's all good stuff. So, yeah, I mean, but it is. I've always felt most useful thing we can do is help other people navigate through life. That's, I guess, the way I would put it in. And mythology is built to help people navigate through life. I mean, my second book. It's an attempt to make meaning. Yeah.
然后在早上，它向一个方向倒下。然后你去棍子告诉你去的地方。伟大的世界轴心。那太好了。所以这就是在创造他们的意义。你知道，如果棍子指向一条河，哦，太好了。棍子想让我们有水。谢谢你，棍子。如果它指向一座山，哦，这是一座神圣的山。意义，你知道，如果棍子指向一条河，哦，太好了，棍子想让我们有水，谢谢你，棍子，如果它指向一座山，哦，这是一座神圣的山，谢谢你，棍子，我很感激，他会和那些棍子丢失的部落交谈
My second book, Living Myths, like each stage of your life has a myth that has got a myth of some culture or many cultures that help you to navigate that phase of your life. I know you've read them, but just for the listeners, in case anyone's not familiar, the Iliad of Merchea did Sacred and the Propheted, which is a pretty early book about study of religion and mythology. One of the things he did was he would find these aboriginal tribes that had a stick, and the whole history of the tribe is written on the stick. And the stick is the tent pole of your tent.
在洪水或被敌人偷走什么的，人们就会漫无目的地游荡并死去，就像他们没有棍子就无法创造意义一样，我们遇到了多少人，对吧，是的，我认为那是问题所在。我们弄丢了我们的棍子，或者我们在为哪根棍子而战，棍子说去不同的方向。但那是原始神话，它只是这是秩序，这是混乱。有人从秩序进入混乱，然后把混乱变成秩序。你知道，那是原始神话。而且，你知道，你可以进入所有让那个过程变得更复杂的原型。
And then in the morning, it falls in a direction. And then you go where the stick tells you to go. And the great world axis. That's so well. So that's what was making their meaning. You know, and if the stick pointed to a river, oh, great. The stick wanted us to have water. Thank you, stick. If it goes to a mountain, oh, it's a holy mountain. meaning you know and if the stick pointed to a river oh great the stick wanted us to have water thank you stick if it goes to a mountain oh it's a holy mountain thank you stick i appreciate it and he would talk to the tribes where the stick would have been lost
但这就是全部。这就是心理学是什么。这就是神话是什么。好吧，我也看印度教神话，对吧？就像，你知道，事情会被创造，它们会衰退，它们会被摧毁，你无法绕过它，但它会一次又一次地发生。我总是告诉人们，我说，你知道，那是一个非常悲观的世界观。我说，真的是吗？不完全是。不完全是。这是一个现实的观点，你知道，我一直在读。而且一切都是梦，愿景正在把一切梦入存在。
in a flood or stolen by an enemy or something and the people would just wander and die like they had no ability to make meaning out of without the stick and how many and how many people do we encounter right yeah i think that's the problem. We've lost our stick or we're fighting about which stick the sticks say to go different directions. But that's the primal myth is it's just this is order and this is chaos. And somebody goes from order into chaos and then turns the chaos into order. You know, that's the primal myth. And, you know, you can get into all the archetypes that make that process more complicated.
但最终，当它醒来时，它就会消失。我们只是，我们只是。好吧，是的，中国哲学家庄子？嗯-嗯。我不知道。对不起，我不是故意打断你的。我只是被庄子的故事刺激了。庄子有这个东西
But that's all it is. It's what psychology is. it's what myth is well i look at and look at hindu mythology too right it's like you know things are going to be created they're going to decay and they're going to be destroyed you can't get around it and but it'll happen again and again and again. And I always tell people, I say, you know, that's a very pessimistic worldview. I say, is it really? Not really. Not really. It's a realistic point of view that, you know, I've been reading. And that everything is a dream, that the vision is dreaming everything into existence.
叫庄周梦蝶。马丁·海德格尔认为这是有史以来最酷的事情。他认为这非常令人兴奋。庄子说，我从一个梦中醒来，梦见我是一只蝴蝶，我，你知道，在花丛中飞来飞去，获取花蜜，所有这些快乐的东西，然后我醒了，我又成了庄周，他说，你知道，啊，我是梦见庄周的蝴蝶，还是梦见自己是蝴蝶的庄周？我只是喜欢那个故事，然后他说，是的，他说，你知道，当蝴蝶很有趣
But eventually, when it wakes up, it'll just be gone. We're just, we're just. Well, yeah, the Chinese philosopher Zhuangzi? Uh-uh. I don't know. I'm sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt you. I just stimulated the Zhuangzi story. Zhuangzi had this thing
你知道，我只是喜欢他那样说，虽然就像，你知道，马丁·海德格尔认为那是一个伟大的故事，他是那个故事的忠实粉丝，这可能对海德格尔的一些东西也是一种挑战，因为他全是语言是存在的家，而且，你知道，你被认知困住了，所以如果你是一只蝴蝶，你没有语言，你仍然存在，你是什么，你知道，很好，而且说，而且确实，是的，他是那个快乐的人，是的，距离我的海德格尔课已经很久了，有趣的是，《存在与时间》在英语中不是一本有趣的读物。不。Un sein。
called Zhuangzi's Butterfly. And Martin Heidegger thought this was the coolest thing ever. He thought this was very exciting. And which Zhuangzi said, I woke up from a dream where i was a butterfly and i was you know flitting about from flower to flower and getting nectar and all this happy stuff and then i woke up and i was juan z again and he said you know ah am i a butterfly that dreams about juan z or my Zhuangzi who dreams about being a butterfly I just love that story and then he said yeah he said you know it was fun being a butterfly
Un sein。无论如何，它在德语中听起来太糟糕了。无论如何，实际上，我是卡尔·雅斯贝尔斯的忠实粉丝。我想他是一位伟大的神话迷。他就是那个提出轴心时代想法的人。所有这些宗教，伟大的宗教思想家在世界各地几乎同时出现。而且，你知道，有些人，我认为确实互相影响，有些人则没有。但他是一个伟大的说，你知道，
you know and I just like the way he said that though it's like you know and Martin Heidegger thought that was a great story he was a big fan of that story it's probably challenging to some of Heidegger's stuff too because he was all that language is the house of being and you know you're trapped with the cognition so if you're a butterfly and you don't have language and you still exist what are you you know fine and saying and does yeah he was the happy guy yeah it's been a long time since my heidegger classes it's funny being in time is not a fun read in English. No. Un sein.
他从不采取荣格的策略，但他是一个伟大的说，你知道，这一切都关乎意义。人们必须，就像你说的关于这个，从棍子中，这一切都关乎意义，每个人想做的每一件事都关乎寻找意义和驾驭生活，而且，你可以告诉人们在生活中期待什么，但直到他们经历它，他们才知道如何驾驭它，这非常，我们的秩序制造，我的意思是，我认为人类本性矛盾的一部分是我们的秩序制造原则，我们的自我，是心理的组织原则，它阻止了我们
Un sein. Anyway, it just sounds so awful in German. Anyway, actually, I'm a great fan, though, of Karl Jaspersen. I guess he was a great fan of myth. And he was the man who came up with the idea of the Axial Age. All these religious, great religious thinkers emerged around the world somewhat simultaneously. And, you know, some, I think, did inform each other and some did not. But he's a great one for saying, you know,
创造意义，因为我们紧紧抓住它，太僵化了，所以我们必须溶解它，然后进入自我之下，甚至进入语言之下，进入身体和情感以及超越空间，这就是我们如何从下降中回来，你知道，就像坎贝尔在英雄之旅中所说的，或者荣格在阴影中所说的，我们带着更大的意义从那里回来，但我们不能完全带走那个地方的所有信息，你知道，我是一个，从那个地方带走信息，你知道，是的，整个生命过程就是寻找上帝背后的上帝，换句话说，嗯-嗯，你认为的上帝会被上帝在现实中对下一阶段的意义所粉碎，直到我不能
he never took a Jungian tact, but he was a great one, though, for saying that, you know, it's all about meaning. People have got, like you said about this in richard out of the stick it's all about meaning everything everybody wants to do is about finding meaning and navigating life and that uh you can tell people what to expect in life but until they experience it they don't know how to navigate it that's very on it our order making i mean i think part of the contradiction of human nature is our order making principle in our ego that is the organizing principle of the psyche is what stops us from
关于那个，因为它不会停止，现实继续展开，正如你所知道的，正如你哭泣的那样，上帝的现实继续展开，正如你所知道的，正如你成长的那样，对吧，这也是自我的互惠，嗯，好吧，我认为这是许多不同心理学模型的问题，它们是完美的，如果你在这里，你知道，所以如果你像从康复中出来，或者如果你21岁，你第一次在大学和男朋友分手，或者这个，你知道，它们在帮助你处理那个方面很好，但你知道，10年、20年的认知行为疗法，我，你知道，我无法想象你会做同样的事情，比如，欧文·亚隆，存在主义哲学家，存在主义心理学家，
making meaning because we cling to it and too rigidly and so we have to dissolve it and then go under the ego and under language even into the body and the emotional and the Transcendental space and that is how we come back from the descent You know like Campbell says in the hero's journey or Jung says with the shadow To we come back with a greater meaning from that, but we can't quite take all of the information from that place with us You know, I was a of the information from that place with us you know yeah a whole process of life is finding God behind God in other words mm-hmm what you think of as God is gonna be shattered by what God is in reality to the next phase thought till I can't
他总是会拿认知的人开玩笑，他们除了自我管理策略之外什么都不做，这很好，你知道，但它总是像，我的意思是，当CBT治疗师生病时，为什么他们不来看我？为什么他们不去另一个CBT治疗师那里，如果它那么好？这是一个脚本，你知道，如果客户这么说，那么你就这么说，这是可手册化的，因为它是可手册化的，你已经知道它是如何工作的，所以去看一个没有意义，而且还有很多人也说他们做CBT，但当你和他们一起治疗或工作时，他们实际上是在做更多依恋存在主义的事情，你知道，他们已经弄清楚了，你知道，医生治愈自己，哦，那太棒了，是的，所以我的意思是，所有这些神话的隐喻，我的意思是，它是
about that because it doesn't stop that the reality continues to unfold as you as you know it and as you cry and reality of god continues to unfold as you as you know it and as you grow right and it's a reciprocity of self as well uh well i think that's the problem with a lot of different models of psychology is that they're perfectly fine if you're here you know so if you're like coming out of recovery or if you're 21 and you're you broke up with your boyfriend for the first time in college or this you know they're they're fine with helping you with that but you know 10 20 years of cognitive behavioral therapy i you know i can't imagine you'd be doing the same thing like what is it ervin yalom's the existential philosopher the existential psychologist and
关于这一点，因为它不会停止，现实会随着你的认知和哭泣不断展开，上帝的现实也会随着你的认知和成长不断展开，对吧？这同样也是一种自我的互惠。嗯，我认为这就是许多不同心理学模型的问题所在，它们在你处于特定阶段时非常管用。比如，如果你刚从康复期走出来，或者你21岁，在大学里第一次和男朋友分手，这些模型在帮助你处理这些问题时是没问题的。但你知道，进行10年、20年的认知行为疗法，我无法想象你还在做同样的事情。就像欧文·亚隆，那位存在主义哲学家、存在主义心理学家，他
he would always kind of poke fun at the cognitive people that um don't really do anything other than uh ego management strategies which are which is fine you know but it was always like i mean when cbt therapists get sick why don't they come see me why don't they go to another cbt therapist if it's so great and it's a script you know you're you're if the client says this then you say this is manualizable and because it's manualizable you already know how it works so there's no point going to see one and then there's a lot of people too who say they do cbt um but then when you sit with them in therapy or you work they're really doing more of an attachment existential thing you know they've figured out you know physician heal thyself oh that's great stuff yeah so i mean all these metaphors for mythology i mean it's
总是会取笑那些认知行为疗法的人，他们除了自我管理策略之外，其实并没有做任何其他事情。这当然没问题，但他的意思是，当认知行为疗法的治疗师生病时，为什么他们不来看我？如果它真的那么好，为什么他们不去找另一位认知行为疗法治疗师？这就像是一个剧本，如果客户说了这个，你就说那个，它是可以手册化的。正因为它能手册化，你已经知道它是如何运作的，所以去看医生也就没有意义了。还有很多人声称自己在做认知行为疗法，但当你和他们一起进行治疗或工作时，他们实际上更多是在做依恋或存在主义方面的事情。你知道，他们已经悟出了“医生，治愈你自己吧”。哦，这太棒了，是的。所以，所有这些关于神话的隐喻，我的意思是它是
that i think that's one of the biggest things is it can kind of take part of psychology. The thing that is challenging is you've got to take people outside of their experience to make them kind of doubt their assumptions. But that is threatening. So you have to do that in a way that doesn't make somebody defensive. And mythology is a great way to do that because you're taking somebody and being like, hey, this is what's going on with you. But you're not saying that. You're being like, you know, there was this centaur, Chaur chiron and he could heal everybody but he had this wound that he couldn't heal i think the reason that he could heal everyone is because he was in such pain and
我认为这是最重要的事情之一，它可以在某种程度上参与心理学。具有挑战性的是，你必须把人们带出他们的经验，让他们对自己的假设产生怀疑。但这具有威胁性。所以你必须以一种不会让对方产生防御心理的方式来做。神话是一个很好的方法，因为你把某人带入其中，就像在说，嘿，这就是你身上发生的事情。但你并没有直接说出来。你就像在说，你知道，曾经有一位半人马，喀戎，他能治愈所有人，但他自己却有一个无法治愈的伤口。我认为他能治愈每个人的原因是他自己也处于极度的痛苦之中，并且
then the person's like oh holy that's me oh my god you know and chiron was a centaur of attention he was a what the centaur of attention oh what do you mean there theaur of attention. Oh, what do you mean then? The center of attention. I was trying to make it that fun. Okay, gotcha. You know, when you have to explain a joke, it's not that good a joke, right? Sorry. The audio kind of dipped for a minute, and I thought I was dismissed. I thought the noise canceling was mushing.
然后那个人就会说，天哪，那是我，天哪，你知道，喀戎是半人马（centaur）……他是注意力的中心（centaur of attention）？哦，你是说注意力的中心（center of attention）。哦，那你是什么意思？注意力的中心。我刚才想让它变得有趣一点。好吧，明白了。你知道，当你不得不解释一个笑话时，它就不是一个好笑话了，对吧？抱歉。音频刚才断了一会儿，我以为我被解雇了。我以为降噪功能把声音弄模糊了。
You know, what's really interesting is when I talk to young people, especially when they're talking about Game of Thrones, I just kind of sit back and grin because hey i can give you games of thrones uh mythology from here till you know heck won't have it right because it's so much of so much of uh and i really what martin wrote in game of thrones is really brilliant but it's all very mythologically based. And all of the themes and archetypes and even episodes are mythologically based. And why does that resonate? Well, you and I know why it resonates, because this is their own human journey.
你知道，真正有趣的是，当我与年轻人交谈时，尤其是当他们谈论《权力的游戏》时，我只是坐下来咧嘴一笑，因为嘿，我可以给你讲从现在到永远的《权力的游戏》神话，因为马丁在《权力的游戏》中写的东西真的很棒，但它完全是基于神话的。所有的主题、原型甚至情节都是基于神话的。为什么这会引起共鸣？嗯，你和我都知道为什么它会引起共鸣，因为这是他们自己的人类旅程。
And, you know, they're seeing things, seeing conflict and seeing issues that may not play, obviously, in the warrior's stance of their daily life, but they play in their daily life. All of those things, you know, betrayal and loyalty and victory and defeat and failure and success. And ambition and not realizing that you're the bad guy. Yeah, exactly. And identifying with your own victimhood and suffering that you don't realize that you're victimizing others. Yes, and scuttling yourself. And that's what I always think is really interesting is telling a person the most painful things you ever tell the other human being is, you know what you're doing is scuttling yourself.
而且，你知道，他们看到的东西，看到的冲突和问题，可能在他们日常生活的战士姿态中并不明显，但它们确实在他们的日常生活中上演。所有这些事情，你知道，背叛、忠诚、胜利、失败、挫折和成功。还有野心，却没意识到自己才是那个坏人。是的，完全正确。并且认同自己的受害者身份和痛苦，却没意识到你正在让别人成为受害者。是的，还有自我毁灭。这就是我一直认为非常有趣的地方，告诉一个人你对另一个人说过的最痛苦的话是，你知道你正在做的事情就是自我毁灭。
But it's true. great theme in mythology. The hero is just blindly rushing ahead and his vulnerability is obvious to all of us watching him. But everyone but him. And then you say that it speaks to the human tendency to be not introspective enough to see where you're going to scuttle
但这是真的。神话中伟大的主题。英雄只是盲目地向前冲，他的脆弱在我们这些看着他的人眼中显而易见。但除了他自己，每个人都看出来了。然后你说这说明了人类倾向于不够内省，无法看到自己将要如何自我毁灭
yourself. I thought that was very interesting. Can you parse what you mean by scuttle there, for the listener? Oh, I'm sorry. Like, you scuttle a shit. Like, you pause the sync. You know, I'm sorry. I'm used to that term.
你自己。我觉得这非常有趣。你能为听众解析一下你在这里说的“自我毁灭”（scuttle）是什么意思吗？哦，抱歉。就像，你凿沉（scuttle）一艘船。就像，你让事情停滞。你知道，抱歉。我习惯用那个词了。
Thank you. Yeah. Just make sure everyone can understand. I mean, we feel like the enemy is out here, but really, the thing defeating us is inside. You trip yourself. That's right. You trip yourself. You defeat. I don't want to use the word defeat yourself because that's a little bit too final.
谢谢。是的。确保每个人都能听懂。我的意思是，我们觉得敌人是在外面，但实际上，打败我们的东西在里面。你自己绊倒了自己。没错。你自己绊倒了自己。你打败了……我不想用“打败”这个词，因为那太绝对了。
But you trip yourself. You set yourself back through choices you've made. You are not seeing the fact that those choices will set you back. Have you ever read Neil Gaiman? You ever read him?
但你绊倒了自己。你通过自己做出的选择阻碍了自己。你没有看到这样一个事实：这些选择会让你倒退。你读过尼尔·盖曼的书吗？你读过吗？
Oh yeah. Yeah. I read a lot of Neil Gaiman in high school. Behind me on the shelves, you will see much Neil Gaiman. I always felt like he was a more interesting thinker than a writer. Like his writing is kind of in service of the idea, not the idea in service of the writing,
哦，是的。是的。我在高中时读了很多尼尔·盖曼的书。在我身后的书架上，你会看到很多尼尔·盖曼的作品。我一直觉得他是一个比作家更有趣的思想家。就像他的写作是为思想服务的，而不是思想为写作服务，
which I like, I like stuff. I get really bored when it's like, people will probably be up in arms, but like something like stuff i get really bored when it's like people will probably be up in arms but like something like lolita like i just i have a hard time going through because it's so well done but it's just kind of this character thing and you're reinforcing the theme and like i want super rich you know density of ideas and the things and and gaiman's not the best writer at least he wasn't um with the american gods era he was kind of shifting from comics to
我喜欢这一点，我喜欢这种东西。当它像……人们可能会群起而攻之，但像《洛丽塔》这样的东西，我读起来很吃力，因为它写得太好了，但它只是一种角色塑造，你在强化主题，而我想要超级丰富、你知道，思想的密度，而盖曼不是最好的作家，至少在《美国众神》时期他不是，他当时正从漫画转向
that but ocean at the end of the lane i really think is like a perfect book it's like that's the book he was trying to write for 10 years so funny i i've always thought of him as a great narrator he was a he was a narrative guy yeah you know he's a structured guy yeah structured Structured guy. Yeah, structured. You know what I mean? How would I put it? Who would you rather have at the coffee pot? Him or Vladimir Nabokov, the guy who wrote Lolita? I would dig Gaiman any day. Yeah. Because I think he's, how do I put it? He's very astute.
那个，但《坟场之书》（Ocean at the End of the Lane）我真的认为是一本完美的书，就像那是他尝试写了10年的书。太搞笑了，我一直认为他是一个伟大的叙述者，他是一个叙事高手。是的，你知道他是一个结构高手。是的，结构。结构高手。是的，结构。你知道我的意思吗？你会更愿意让谁在咖啡壶旁？是他还是弗拉基米尔·纳博科夫，那个写《洛丽塔》的人？我随时都会选盖曼。是的。因为我觉得他，怎么说呢？他非常敏锐。
He is very attuned and intuitive to human beings that would make them tick and that's why i always like i always like robert graves for that reason because yeah he was very good and said you know here's what happened that myth now what does that make you think about what does that remind you of that was like he doesn't say it in so many words but he leads you that point like well now what does that remind you of and i love that because it's like somebody said to me why in the heck are you reading mythology that stuff is dead that stuff's old it's like i don't hear it let's open a myth and i do the work and let's read it who does that remind you of does that ring a bell and it always does well in in the an ocean in the end of the
他对人类非常协调和直觉，知道是什么让他们动心，这就是为什么我一直喜欢罗伯特·格雷夫斯的原因，因为是的，他非常擅长说，你知道，这就是那个神话发生的事情，现在这让你想到了什么？这让你想起了什么？他没有用那么多话来说，但他引导你到那个点，就像，好吧，现在这让你想起了什么？我喜欢这一点，因为就像有人对我说，你为什么要读神话？那些东西已经死了，那些东西太老了。就像，我没听见，让我们打开一个神话，我来做这项工作，让我们读一读，这让你想起了谁？这听起来耳熟吗？而且总是这样。嗯，在《坟场之书》里
lane kind of what we were talking about that making order out of chaos and that all psychology is this descent to let go of what we think we are to become what we really are and accept change and all that and there's like a metaphor towards the end of that book where the narrator's talking about going into the ocean and they're like as they are dissolving in the ocean they're like I am able to understand how everything works I'm able to see from all perspectives I'm able to understand I see everything so clearly but that can't fit into a person and if you stay there you become nothing yeah I'm everything that you become nothing because you dissolve you know and look at the Bhagavad Gita Gita with Arjuna and Krishna's conversation. It's like if you do what you think you're supposed to do, you're going to be doing exactly the wrong thing.
那种我们谈论的从混乱中建立秩序，以及所有的心理学都是这种下降，为了放下我们认为我们是什么，从而成为我们真正是什么，并接受变化等等。在那本书的结尾有一个隐喻，叙述者谈到进入海洋，他们就像在海洋中溶解时，他们说我能够理解一切是如何运作的，我能够从所有角度看问题，我能够理解，我看得如此清晰，但这无法装进一个人体内，如果你留在那里，你就变得什么都不是。是的，我是一切，但你变得什么都不是，因为你溶解了。你知道，看看《薄伽梵歌》中阿周那和克里希纳的对话。就像如果你做你认为你应该做的事，你做的将完全是错误的事。
And if you do what you're supposed to do, it's going to break your heart. And I always thought that was just the most brilliant analysis of human life right well and um uh the bhagavad-gita my that's one of my favorite lines is that behold i have become time even without your sword all these warriors which turn into dust and die he's trying he's the book if anyone it's a it's a hindu religious book but um vision is trying to convince a prince to go into a battle and fight and the prince is trying to nail gaze and not do it well he's showing him i meant to kill my relatives that's yeah he's he's trying to avoid you know this complicated decision and he says you know well look i've become time even without your sword all these people will turn to dust and die even if you do nothing yeah and the other thing i always like
如果你做你应该做的事，它会让你心碎。我一直认为这是对人类生活最精彩的分析。好吧，嗯，《薄伽梵歌》……我最喜欢的台词之一是“看哪，我已经成为了时间，即使没有你的剑，所有这些战士也会化为尘土而死”。他试图……他是这本书，如果有人……这是一本印度教宗教书籍，但……毗湿奴正试图说服一位王子去参加战斗并战斗，而王子正试图……盯着指甲，不想这样做。好吧，他向他展示了……我本意是杀掉我的亲戚，那是……是的，他试图避免，你知道，这个复杂的决定，他说，你知道，好吧，看，我已经成为了时间，即使没有你的剑，所有这些人也会化为尘土而死，即使你什么都不做。是的，还有另一件事我一直喜欢
that too is arjuna is the uh is the audience's perspective in this story. It's part of a greater thing called the Mahabharata, which is a Hindu epic. And it's the segment of where Arjuna the charioteer is about to go into battle against his cousins. And it's the epic battle of good and evil. But some are good and some are evil and some are a little bit more good than evil and there's a little bit more going on there and uh krishna shows up and says you know you've got to do something this is your duty okay you are this is your dharma this is what you were made to do and the guys yeah i don't want to do this just here are the reasons why that's a great discussion because like every human being goes through that
那个也一样，阿周那是这个故事中观众的视角。它是《摩诃婆罗多》这一伟大作品的一部分，这是一部印度史诗。这是阿周那作为战车御者即将与他的堂兄弟们开战的片段。这是善与恶的史诗般的战斗。但有些是善的，有些是恶的，有些比恶多一点善，还有更多的事情在发生，克里希纳出现了，说你知道你必须做点什么，这是你的职责，好吧，你是……这是你的“达摩”（dharma），这是你被创造出来要做的，而那家伙说，是的，我不想这样做，这里是原因。那是一场很棒的讨论，因为每个人都会经历那种情况。
well it's not really about war or not war it's about the way that we make decisions and make meaning i mean so many of the people who are citing um the bhagavad-gita like gandhi they're they're citing it as a work of arguing for peace and arguing for non-violence but the whole text is a debate about a guy needs to go fight a war against his family but the context is where what leads to the point you just made which is in regards to who ends this war you're all going to be gone victory is your victory is not that it's not that big a deal and there are no winners in time no and it's certainly this is how it is and I love reading about the vodka ties read it many many many times in fact on my bedstead I've got a Bible and I have Gandhi's translation of the Bhagavad Gita because
嗯，这其实不是关于战争还是不战争，而是关于我们做决定和赋予意义的方式。我的意思是，这么多引用《薄伽梵歌》的人，比如甘地，他们引用它是为了主张和平和非暴力，但整部文本是一场关于一个人需要去和他的家人打一场战争的辩论，但背景是导致你刚才提到的那一点，即关于谁结束了这场战争，你们都将消失，胜利……你的胜利并不是什么大不了的事，在时间面前没有赢家。不，当然是这样。我喜欢读《薄伽梵歌》，读过很多很多次。事实上，在我的床头，我有一本圣经，还有甘地翻译的《薄伽梵歌》，因为
yeah little commentaries in there in the margins of where's what I think was in Arjuna's mind Here's a professional is trying to tell him it was written is His translation was written for businessmen and people who really didn't work Sanskrit scholars But we need it needed to read the Bhagavad Gita It's my favorite version that I had well, I mean, I think we've kind of answered the question about why mythology is important to study and why it's a part of psychology what about poetry I mean that's the other half of the stuff that you do you report now you've got a blog about poetry
是的，在页边空白处有小评论，关于我认为阿周那在想什么。这是一个专业人士试图告诉他，它是为商人和那些真正不是梵文学者的人写的，但我们需要读《薄伽梵歌》。这是我拥有的最喜欢的版本。好吧，我的意思是，我想我们已经回答了关于为什么研究神话很重要以及为什么它是心理学的一部分的问题。那诗歌呢？我的意思是，那是你做的另一半事情。你现在有一个关于诗歌的博客。
do you publish poems on print or do you just do them on the web I'm doing on the blog now and I'm in the process of doing some in and i'm in the process of doing some in print i'm also the process of translating my poetry to turkish uh which is that's my little intellectual exercise to keep me keep my old brain uh cells working but i've had a really good response to the website and encourage people of course to look at it and also make comments uh and we'll link to it in the show notes. Sure. And one of the things I put in there, by the way,
你是在印刷品上发表诗歌，还是只在网上发表？我现在在博客上做，我正在进行一些……我正在进行一些印刷版的工作。我也在把我的诗歌翻译成土耳其语，这是我的一点智力练习，为了让我的大脑细胞保持工作。但我对网站的反应非常好，当然也鼓励人们去看它，并发表评论，我们会在节目说明中提供链接。当然。顺便说一句，我放在那里的一件事是，
is the critics were somewhat right, is what I say, because I address the issue of criticism and how when you are doing anything like writing or painting or thinking, that there's criticism. And how do you take constructive criticism and in retrospect you realize that a lot of the criticism whatever the person's motive is useful is very useful and helps you to think and you can say yeah well his or her uh you know motive was terrible they were just this isn't like okay but maybe they said something you may want to consider.
评论家们在某种程度上是对的，这是我说的，因为我谈到了批评的问题，以及当你做任何事情，比如写作、绘画或思考时，都会有批评。你如何接受建设性的批评，事后你会意识到，很多批评，无论那个人的动机是什么，都是有用的，非常有用的，可以帮助你思考，你可以说，是的，好吧，他或她的动机很糟糕，他们只是……这不是像……好吧，但也许他们说了一些你可能想考虑的事情。
And that was one topic I've done. But I try to do things that I think I listen to people, and I try to do things that help them navigate, right? And somewhat informed by mythology, somewhat informed by introspection and philosophy. A couple of the poems that are really popular, mean if i may i'll read them for you that would be wonderful i'd love for you to read some oh thanks well the one that is most popular and written is uh unselfing and there's a prologue to it where taran russell uses the term unselfing to describe the practice of going outside yourself, your needs, and your present situation to connect with others and with things greater than oneself.
那是我的一个主题。但我尝试做我认为……我倾听人们的意见，我尝试做一些帮助他们导航的事情，对吧？并且在某种程度上受到神话、内省和哲学的启发。有几首诗非常受欢迎，如果可以的话，我会为你读一下。那太棒了，我很乐意让你读一些。哦，谢谢。好吧，最受欢迎的一首是《去自我化》（Unselfing），它有一个序言，塔兰·拉塞尔用“去自我化”这个词来描述走出你自己、你的需求和你当前处境，去与他人以及比自身更伟大的事物连接的实践。
Hmm, I should say yourself. I realize inconsistency there. In Russell's case, the wonders of science, mathematics, and the universe. This led to a meditation on unselfing. For Christians, it seems particularly appropriate during Lent, which is now. Now, I also think it's very fitting for Muslims at Ramadan. So, I'll read it for you. Myself is me. Imagine myself as a hot air balloon with many heavy rocks attached to it by ropes, anchoring it firmly to the ground. The balloon is my spirit,
嗯，我应该说你自己。我意识到那里有不一致。在拉塞尔的例子中，是科学、数学和宇宙的奇迹。这导致了对“去自我化”的冥想。对于基督徒来说，这在四旬斋期间似乎特别合适，现在正是时候。现在，我也认为这对穆斯林的斋月非常合适。所以，我会为你读一下。自我就是我。想象我自己是一个热气球，上面系着许多沉重的石头，用绳子把它们锚定在地面上。气球是我的精神，
and the rocks are my own concerns, needs, wishes, worries, desires, preoccupations, preconceived notions, prejudices, fears, and worries about things that will never happen. If I am in this balloon and look down, that is all I see. I look up, however, I see the infinite sky. And I know that if I cut the ropes to these rocks weighing me down, the balloon will soar and I will see new panoramas. I will see others. I will see the place I had been from a loftier height and see just how small it is. Unself, cut the ropes to your own petty concerns and soar.
而石头是我自己的担忧、需求、愿望、烦恼、欲望、先入为主的观念、偏见、恐惧，以及对那些永远不会发生的事情的担忧。如果我在这个气球里往下看，我看到的就只有这些。然而，当我抬头看时，我看到了无限的天空。我知道，如果我割断这些压着我的石头的绳子，气球就会翱翔，我就会看到新的全景。我会看到其他人。我会从更高的高度看到我曾经所在的地方，并看到它是多么渺小。去自我化，割断你那些琐碎担忧的绳子，翱翔吧。
Move higher towards visions beyond myself, toward things greater than the self where I am. My spirit will rise beyond the self that weighs me down. And as I rise and soar, what was once large becomes small. My heart expands beyond me to embrace others and what was small in my spirit becomes greater as it rises that was beautiful thank you that was fun i enjoyed it i do my writing of poems i'm going to tell you this is kind of fun early early in the morning when i first get up i think i ponder ponder, I meditate, I read things,
向着超越自我的愿景，向着比自我更伟大的事物移动，在那里我……我的精神将超越压垮我的自我。当我上升和翱翔时，曾经巨大的东西变得渺小。我的心超越了我去拥抱他人，而我精神中渺小的东西随着它的上升变得更加伟大。那太美了，谢谢。那很有趣，我很享受。我写诗……我要告诉你，这很有趣，在清晨，当我刚起床时，我思考、冥想，我读一些东西，
and I make little notes, right? And I do that one day. And the poem usually gets written a day or two later because I then end up arguing with myself saying, that's not what you want to say. That's kind of stupid. Or that's, I really, that sounds awfully, you know, Vaseline on the lens, Hallmark-y, so don't do that. And so that's how really that sounds awfully uh you know vaseline on the lens uh hallmarky so don't do that and so that's how these things come out another one i'm going to read is one of my most popular ones i've seen getting good feedback on it's called what does it matter to me and i'm going to warn you up front it's very straightforward not a lot of of uh metaphor to work through anything it starts with a quote if you, if you feel pain, you are alive.
我做一些小笔记，对吧？我有一天这样做。这首诗通常在一两天后写成，因为我最终会和自己争论，说，那不是你想说的。那有点蠢。或者那……听起来太……你知道，镜头上涂了凡士林，像贺卡一样，所以不要那样做。所以这就是这些东西出来的过程。我要读的另一首是我最受欢迎的诗之一，我看到它得到了很好的反馈，它叫《那对我有什么关系？》，我要提前警告你，它非常直白，没有太多隐喻需要去理解。它以一句引语开头：如果你感到痛苦，你就活着。
If you feel another's pain, you're a human. What does, and guess what this is inspired by, by the way. I'll let you hear the whole poem go. Oh, yeah, I get it. What does it matter to me when there's a war on the other side of the earth? Very sad. Quite tragic. Sorry to hear about that.
如果你感到他人的痛苦，你就是一个人。那……猜猜这是受什么启发的，顺便说一句。我会让你听完整首诗。哦，是的，我明白了。当地球另一端发生战争时，那对我有什么关系？非常悲伤。相当悲惨。很遗憾听到这个消息。
But it isn't my war. What does it matter when there's an earthquake on the other side of the earth that kills as many people as live in most small towns? Tragic. I feel sorry for them. What a shame. Should I buy a hot tub?
但那不是我的战争。当地球另一端发生地震，杀死了像大多数小城镇一样多的人时，那有什么关系？悲惨。我为他们感到难过。真可惜。我应该买个热水浴缸吗？
We really should install track lighting in the dining room. What does it matter that a child is hungry on the other end of the earth? After all, people shouldn't have so many children. Well, it matters, I suppose, really, but they always have problems there. If it's on the other side of the world, I really can't see it. So it doesn't exist. It doesn't matter. Or does it matter matter it isn't my problem if it appears on the screen i can change the channel and relax by watching a zombie
我们真的应该在餐厅安装轨道灯。地球另一端的一个孩子挨饿，那有什么关系？毕竟，人们不应该生那么多孩子。嗯，我想这确实有关系，但他们那里总是有问题。如果它在世界的另一端，我真的看不见它。所以它不存在。它没关系。或者它有关系吗？如果它不是我的问题，如果它出现在屏幕上，我可以换频道，通过看僵尸
apocalypse the human condition is so tragic but it's not my condition well perhaps that's the real tragedy because they're humans and then there's me. My indifference means that I'm not human, but some other kind of creature. But if I see the things I'd rather not see, it will make me human, and then those things will matter to me. The empty stomach of a child will become the emptiness in my heart.
启示录来放松。人类的状况是如此悲惨，但那不是我的状况。嗯，也许那才是真正的悲剧，因为他们是人，而我是我。我的冷漠意味着我不是人，而是某种其他生物。但如果我看到了我不想看到的东西，它会让我成为人，然后那些事情就会与我有关。一个孩子空空的胃将成为我心中的空虚。
The empty hand of another will matter when it touches my hand. And fullness of soul is when other souls matter. The empty hand of another will matter when it touches my hand. And fullness of soul is when other souls matter. Beauty of face is not an expensive cream, but in seeing the beauty of another human face in our eyes. And the best defense against aging is a maturity that is so young that it sees itself in a hungry child.
另一个人的空手，当它触碰我的手时，就会有关系。灵魂的充实是当其他灵魂变得重要时。另一个人的空手，当它触碰我的手时，就会有关系。灵魂的充实是当其他灵魂变得重要时。面容的美丽不是昂贵的面霜，而是在我们的眼中看到另一个人面容的美丽。而对抗衰老的最好防御是一种成熟，它如此年轻，以至于它在饥饿的孩子身上看到了自己。
And you both matter a little bit. And you both are undeniably human. Perhaps human evolution means becoming more human. And the discovery of the amount of room in the human heart is our next great discovery. Wow. There is a complexity to that. That is very affecting. Thank you, sir. I appreciate that. That is very affecting. Thank you, sir.
你们两个都有点重要。你们两个都不可否认是人类。也许人类进化意味着变得更像人。而发现人类心中空间的大小是我们下一个伟大的发现。哇。那里面有一种复杂性。那非常感人。谢谢你，先生。我很感激。那非常感人。谢谢你，先生。
I appreciate that. Appreciate the kind words. I hadn't seen that one on your blog. Is that an older one? Oh, yeah. It's ancient, February 11th. It's an old timer. Would you like another one, or am I going to get more of you?
我很感激。感谢你的好话。我没在你的博客上看到那一篇。那是旧的吗？哦，是的。它很古老，2月11日的。它是个老古董。你想要另一首，还是我要从你那里得到更多？
No, no, please. And say the website, too, so people can make sure they can find you everywhere that you are. Very hard to find. It's jfbeerline.com. But now, since my name is not quite phonetic in English, it's B-I-E-R-L-E-I-N. And absolutely. And since I'm a great lover of gardening and wine, I planted lots of grapes. And I wrote a poem about it called Dormant.
不，不，请。也说一下网站，这样人们可以确保在任何地方都能找到你。很难找到。是 jfbeerline.com。但现在，因为我的名字在英语中不太符合拼写规则，是 B-I-E-R-L-E-I-N。绝对的。而且因为我是一个园艺和葡萄酒的忠实爱好者，我种了很多葡萄。我写了一首关于它的诗，叫《休眠》（Dormant）。
I just love that word. Does it sound awful? Dormant. I planted some grapes and was warned that they looked dead, but they're merely dormant. Sure enough, beyond beneath that appearance, I nicked the vine with my jackknife and saw green inside. But the right combination of sun, rain, and warm soil, and it will spring to life, send out shoots, and eventually yield fat,
我就是喜欢那个词。听起来很糟糕吗？休眠。我种了一些葡萄，被警告说它们看起来死了，但它们只是休眠了。果然，在那外表之下，我用折叠刀划开了藤蔓，看到了里面的绿色。但阳光、雨水和温暖土壤的正确组合，它就会焕发生机，长出嫩芽，最终结出肥硕、
juicy grapes. I will drink that wine for many years to come. It would have been easy to declare the vines dead. By all appearances, they were gone. What a waste that would have been. There have been dormant times in my life and yours. Things seem dead, inert, even sterile, completely devoid of any growth. In these times of anxiety and fear, I had to reach deep inside myself to find that speck of green. It seems that nothing would bear fruit, and that one is at a dead end. Others may have decided that you were finished and done, but you weren't. It appears so to them, but if you know there's still that green alive in you, with the right combination of hope, faith, and the warm soil of the heart, you too will sprout out and
多汁的葡萄。我将在未来的许多年里喝那杯酒。宣布藤蔓死亡很容易。从各方面来看，它们都消失了。那将是多么大的浪费。在我的生活中，在你的生活中，都有过休眠的时期。事情看起来死了，惰性的，甚至是贫瘠的，完全没有任何生长。在这些焦虑和恐惧的时刻，我不得不深入内心去寻找那一点点绿色。似乎没有任何东西会结出果实，而且一个人走到了死胡同。其他人可能已经断定你完了，结束了，但你没有。在他们看来是这样，但如果你知道你内心仍然有那种绿色的生命，只要有希望、信仰和心灵温暖土壤的正确组合，你也会发芽并
reach out your branches. You have no idea of the fruit you'll bear. You have no idea of what fine things will come with the years. Learn the magic, that the magic of dormancy is not death but the staging for magnificent things and learn the mystery of seasons in our life and the hope arising that seasons change and of the seasons last but we can it's beautiful thank you thank you thank you so much oh my pleasure i have to garden some more and write some more poems. Yeah, I need to.
伸展你的枝条。你不知道你将结出什么样的果实。你不知道随着岁月的流逝，会有什么美好的事情发生。学习魔法，休眠的魔法不是死亡，而是宏伟事物的舞台，学习我们生活中季节的奥秘，以及季节变化带来的希望，季节会持续，但我们可以……这很美，谢谢，谢谢，非常感谢。哦，我的荣幸。我得再多做点园艺，再多写点诗。是的，我需要。
Do you do audio recordings of any of them? Sometimes, like, we're noticing that younger generations, like, I recommend books or something. Like, they won't do it unless it's recorded. But, you know, the Audible seems to be boosting everyone's sales. Well, I think we'll have to do this. We'll have to do this and credit Joel Blackstock on his excellent suggestion. I think that's a great idea. Audible publishing is pretty easy.
你有没有做过任何诗的音频录音？有时，比如，我们注意到年轻一代，比如，我推荐书什么的。比如，除非有录音，否则他们不会看。但是，你知道，Audible似乎正在提升每个人的销量。嗯，我想我们必须这样做。我们必须这样做，并把功劳归于乔尔·布莱克斯托克（Joel Blackstock）的绝佳建议。我认为这是一个好主意。Audible出版很容易。
You need a nice mic. You can read it yourself and just upload it. And then if it sells, they send you a cut of it. Amazon does. Well, all right. We'll investigate that, Joel. I mean, actually, I will pick your brain at another time and we'll figure it out in the next track. Yeah, it's funny.
你需要一个好的麦克风。你可以自己读，然后上传。如果它卖出去了，他们会给你分成。亚马逊会。好吧，好吧。我们会调查一下，乔尔。我的意思是，实际上，我会找时间向你请教，我们会在下一条轨道中弄清楚。是的，这很有趣。
A lot of people who are aspiring writers have sent emails and i've told them that or or current writers um but if you got books that haven't sold for a while or something you know they're not highly circulated you can just go back and either pay somebody you know 200 bucks to record the book uh with on fiverr or something one of those contractor sites where you just read it yourself and upload it and uh people looking for an audiobook they have the audible subscription we'll start doing it and it will old classics are getting rediscovered that way and also too i mean if any of your patients have issues with insomnia i can read that'll help so you can help you ever read pen warren robert pit warren oh yeah i love robert pen warren his stuff
很多有抱负的作家发过邮件，我告诉过他们，或者现任作家……但如果你有书卖不动了，或者你知道它们流通量不高，你可以回去，要么付给某人，你知道，200美元在Fiverr或那些承包商网站之一上录制这本书，或者你自己读，然后上传，那些寻找有声书的人，他们有Audible订阅，我们会开始这样做，旧经典会以这种方式被重新发现。而且，我的意思是，如果你的任何病人有失眠问题，我可以读，那会有帮助，所以你可以帮助……你读过罗伯特·潘·沃伦（Robert Penn Warren）吗？哦，是的，我喜欢罗伯特·潘·沃伦，他的东西
is very hard to find like in nashville my friend lived in nashville and said there were all these he would go to all these antique stores and use book places and we had all these books and then throughout the year some of them got lost and i was like well i'll just order another copy and it's like you can't find a ton of his poetry anthologies of modern quote unquote and i say in quote unquote american verse that my mom bought in like 1958 or something and i still have that thing and i got it all marked up and it's got post-it notes and coffee stains and i think tears i think it's got all the words in there and that book contains a number of his poems i think a way to love god and waiting are two of my favorite ones oh they're lovely i i also i'm a big big fan of um well t.s
很难找到，比如在纳什维尔，我的朋友住在纳什维尔，说有所有这些……他会去所有这些古董店和旧书店，我们有所有这些书，然后一年中有些丢了，我就想，好吧，我再订一本，结果你找不到他的诗集，现代的，引用“现代”美国诗歌，我妈妈在1958年左右买的，我还有那个东西，我把它全画满了，有便利贴和咖啡渍，我想还有眼泪，我想里面有所有的词，那本书包含了他的一些诗，我想《爱上帝的方式》和《等待》是我最喜欢的两首。哦，它们很可爱。我……我也是……嗯，我很喜欢T.S.
elliott i'm a big fan of t.s elliott i'm also a great fan of uh frost i know frost has become kind of overly popular but frost is very good for navigating. Well, and overly romanticized. I mean, a lot of his stuff is a lot bleaker than people will let it be. Oh, that was. You know, the story about him waking his daughter up at night. Are you familiar with that? I don't know that story. He was drinking whiskey, and he went and got his daughter up with his gun
艾略特，我很喜欢T.S.艾略特，我也很喜欢弗罗斯特。我知道弗罗斯特已经变得有点过于流行了，但弗罗斯特非常适合导航。嗯，而且被过度浪漫化了。我的意思是，他的很多东西比人们允许的要凄凉得多。哦，那是。你知道，关于他在晚上叫醒他女儿的故事吗？你熟悉那个故事吗？我不知道那个故事。他在喝威士忌，他拿着枪去叫醒他女儿
and was like, come downstairs, and kept holding the gun and being like, do you love more me or your mom and drinking whiskey until she was like no dad i can't choose and then the sun came up and he got tired and he finally went to bed but it's just like he was not a well guy well i kind of changed a few things i didn't have to go back and do some revisiting of frost uh that came from my poetry professor at swanee so i've always seen that happen firsthand i've never heard that before but that is well i want to know why a prunty was the professor who taught uh poetry to me and he was swanee so he had known he knew a lot of things about poets especially the southern agrarians and the inklings that were not common knowledge because he knew people who
就像，下楼来，一直拿着枪，就像，你更爱我还是你妈妈？并喝着威士忌，直到她说，不，爸爸，我不能选择。然后太阳升起来了，他累了，终于上床睡觉了，但这就像……他不是一个健康的人。嗯，我改变了一些事情，我不得不回去重新审视弗罗斯特，那来自我在塞瓦尼（Sewanee）的诗歌教授，所以我一直亲眼目睹这种情况。我以前从未听说过，但那是……嗯，我想知道为什么阿普伦蒂（Prunty）是教我诗歌的教授，他在塞瓦尼，所以他知道很多关于诗人的事情，特别是南方农业派和“墨水瓶”（Inklings），这些不是常识，因为他认识那些
had seen it so he knew the dirt on the people so it's like would be at swanee he'd be like oh that's the balance that's the balcony that alan tate held this other poet off because and he said he was going to drop him if he didn't recount all the women had slept with and then all the women left the party and then it turned into this huge rager and then this other poem was composed i don't even remember all the stories but it's just like you know things you can't google because they were first or second hand accounts of these guys you hear these things and boy you feel very well adjusted you know i always get a kick out of that i hear the string go really that's that's something that's pretty uh that's pretty edgy behind the flowery language you know is this
亲眼见过的人，所以他知道这些人的底细。所以就像在塞瓦尼，他会说，哦，那是艾伦·泰特（Alan Tate）把另一位诗人悬在上面的阳台，因为……他说如果他不复述所有他睡过的女人，他就会把他扔下去，然后所有的女人都离开了派对，然后它变成了一场巨大的狂欢，然后另一首诗被创作出来了。我甚至不记得所有的故事，但这就像，你知道，你无法谷歌的事情，因为它们是这些家伙的第一手或第二手资料。你听到这些事情，天哪，你感觉自己非常适应，你知道，我总是从中得到乐趣。我听到弦乐……真的，那是……那是相当……在华丽的语言背后，那是相当尖锐的，你知道，这是
insanity or what pinhorn was really good friends with uh what's his name who behind the flowery language you know is this insanity or what it was really good friends with what's his name who's the guy that wrote dope deliverance Oh not Vicki yeah I was gonna say Duffy and that's wrong that was and Vicki I think Vicki was stalking at Swanee like right before he died of alcohol to Vicki was Vie had a had a rough life dickie was horribly golly you're talking about people with depression dickie was on the top of that list he's pretty serious i'm trying to who else was i just finished reading the the joel cohen is super into you know the cohen brothers he loves existentialism and spinoza and all this stuff and he spent a really long time trying to get the james dickie book made he's good there's a script of joel cohen adapting a
疯狂还是什么？潘·沃伦和……叫什么名字的人是好朋友，在华丽的语言背后，你知道，这是疯狂还是什么？他和……叫什么名字的人是好朋友，那个写《救赎》（Deliverance）的人？哦，不是维基（Vicki），是的，我本来想说迪基（Dickey），那是错的，那是……还有维基，我想维基在塞瓦尼，就在他死于酒精之前，维基……维基有一个艰难的生活，迪基，迪基有一个艰难的生活，迪基，天哪，你在谈论患有抑郁症的人，迪基在那个名单的顶端。他很严肃，我正在尝试……还有谁……我刚读完乔尔·科恩（Joel Coen），他非常喜欢，你知道科恩兄弟，他喜欢存在主义和斯宾诺莎以及所有这些东西，他花了很多时间试图把詹姆斯·迪基（James Dickey）的书拍成电影。他很好，有一个乔尔·科恩改编的剧本
james dickie book which is really interesting spinoza's best quote that i liked i tell everyone when i have a chances but peter says about paul tells you more about peter than does about paul that is from spinoza, believe it or not. I always thought that was a brilliant quote. Well, the thing I like about Penn Warren is his books are kind of poems, and his poetry
詹姆斯·迪基的书，这非常有趣。斯宾诺莎最好的引语，我喜欢的，我每次有机会都会告诉每个人，但彼得说保罗，告诉你关于彼得的比关于保罗的多。那是斯宾诺莎说的，信不信由你。我一直认为那是一句精彩的引语。嗯，我喜欢潘·沃伦的一点是，他的书有点像诗，而他的诗
is kind of prose. And that's why I'd ask you, because you were reading something that was just a series of statements that was not overly ornate that turns into, just by the way that these simple statements are arranged this beautiful thing and pen warren would kind of do that where he's just being like oh you know the way that sheep chew grass and their eyes watch the sky yes yes i know what you're saying and and and pen warren has a very nice way of lulling you into this happy place and then biting you. You know what I mean?
有点像散文。这就是为什么我会问你，因为你读的东西只是一系列陈述，并不过于华丽，但仅仅通过这些简单陈述的排列，就变成了这件美丽的东西。潘·沃伦会做那种事，他只是说，哦，你知道，羊咀嚼草的方式，它们的眼睛看着天空。是的，是的，我知道你在说什么。而且潘·沃伦有一种非常好的方式，让你进入这个快乐的地方，然后咬你一口。你知道我的意思吗？
It's like, it's like you lulled into, well, this is a pretty bucolic image. And all of a sudden, boom, something, something nasty hits. That's that in waiting.
就像，就像你被哄骗进，嗯，这是一个相当田园的意象。突然间，砰，一些……一些讨厌的东西击中了。那是《等待》中的那部分。
And it's like, you think I speak in riddles, but I don't. Yeah, exactly. The world means nothing but itself. It's lovely. I'm glad you enjoyed that poem. and I'm glad you enjoyed the poetry.
就像，你以为我说话像谜语，但我没有。是的，完全正确。世界除了它本身什么也不是。这很可爱。我很高兴你喜欢那首诗。我也很高兴你喜欢这些诗。
It's wonderful. And my wife likes to, I think I've never seen her roll her eyes harder than when our daughter, our first child, was taking her first step, and she was like, oh, my gosh, and Violet stood up and walked, and Violet recited the Ovid, the animals must cast their gaze upon the grass to trod, but humankind can stand erect to avert its eyes to God. She's just like, oh!
这太棒了。我妻子喜欢……我想我从未见过她翻白眼翻得比我们女儿，我们的第一个孩子，迈出第一步时更厉害，她就像，哦，天哪，维奥莱特（Violet）站起来走了，维奥莱特背诵了奥维德（Ovid）的诗，“动物必须把目光投向草地才能行走，但人类可以站直，把目光投向上帝。”她就像，哦！
It's priceless. Yeah. Oh, man. Well, can you talk about the transition from mythology to poetry you know we know as mythology was poetry or is poetry sure sure uh you know the the greatest thing you i always tell people is they say well what's the difference in mythology and poetry i'll say well go see ovid go see heshet go see homer go see the writers of the mahabrata go see these guys look at them it's all poetry it was recited as poetry uh the epics the recited
这是无价的。是的。哦，天哪。好吧，你能谈谈从神话到诗歌的过渡吗？你知道我们知道神话就是诗歌，或者就是诗歌。当然，当然，嗯，你知道，我总是告诉人们最伟大的事情是，他们说，嗯，神话和诗歌有什么区别？我会说，好吧，去看看奥维德，去看看赫西奥德（Hesiod），去看看荷马，去看看《摩诃婆罗多》的作者，去看看这些人，看看他们，这全是诗歌。它被背诵为诗歌……史诗，背诵的
epics they all are poetry and poetry has always been the way of conveyance of the elements of meaning well in pre-writing that was how you would memorize it you know if somebody told the story you could change stuff but if i you know somebody else could invent a new thing but if every end of the line rhymes with the next thing and there's a meter then you can't change it you gotta you know what's funny is people immediately recognize poetry as separate from prose or basic narrative instantly. It's almost like I don't even know if they have to be taught. It's a fascinating thing to me.
史诗，它们全是诗歌。诗歌一直是传达意义要素的方式。嗯，在文字出现之前，那是你记忆它的方式。你知道，如果有人讲故事，你可以改变东西，但如果我……你知道，别人可以发明新东西，但如果每一行的结尾都与下一行押韵，并且有格律，那么你就不能改变它，你必须……你知道有趣的是，人们立即将诗歌识别为不同于散文或基本叙事。这几乎就像我甚至不知道他们是否需要被教导。这对我来说是一件迷人的事情。
I think there's some innate poetic thing going on with people. And in mythology, it works the same way. They instinctively know what the story is. They instinctively know that it's not an objective recounting of something you know it's like I always find fascinating both poetry mythology you have to explain to people the difference from usually at least they're most sane people I should say you don't have to explain the difference from that from normal stated narrative and they know that conveys something different than normal stated narrative. And, you know, a few times I recall talking to people and I remember years ago, this person speaking poetically.
我认为人们有一种天生的诗意。在神话中，它以同样的方式运作。他们本能地知道故事是什么。他们本能地知道这不是对某事的客观叙述，你知道，就像我总是觉得迷人，诗歌和神话，你必须向人们解释与通常至少最理智的人的区别，我应该说，你不必解释与正常陈述叙事的区别，他们知道它传达的东西与正常陈述叙事不同。而且，你知道，有几次我记得和人们交谈，我记得几年前，这个人诗意地说话。
They don't know they are, but they're speaking poetically. And I would tell them, I'd say, what do you mean by that? And I would say, you're not speaking in normal narrative. It's not like, you know know we need some coffee creamer uh you're speaking about conveying to me a very cons very complicated concept of negotiating our way through human existence in a relatively simple way that i can grasp and that i think is what poetry and mythology do yeah and i think there's something about poetry that when people have kind of a rigid ego when they kind of cling to logic or existential whatever it bothers them you know yeah um yeah i don't remember you know there's certain types of people
他们不知道他们是，但他们诗意地说话。我会告诉他们，我会说，你那是什么意思？我会说，你不是在用正常的叙事说话。这不像，你知道，我们需要一些咖啡伴侣……你是在谈论向我传达一个非常复杂的概念，关于以一种我可以掌握的相对简单的方式协商我们通过人类生存的道路，我认为这就是诗歌和神话所做的。是的，我认为诗歌有一种东西，当人们有一种僵化的自我时，当他们坚持逻辑或存在主义什么的，它会困扰他们，你知道。是的，嗯，是的，我不记得，你知道，有某些类型的人
that if a poem or something is in the book, they start to roll their eyes. I think it's a lot of why Carl Jung is on the outside of the medical institution and probably always will be. What is it in school they said? You can't be a Jungian because there's no way to objectively disprove it, the theory. The theory isn't valid because there's no way to objectively disprove it. It's like there's no way to disprove a metaphor like it's not a literal psychology it's yeah it wasn't built that way you know his book the end answer to joe is uh i always felt was an amazing piece of poetry really you understand the answer to joe it's very good and it's it's the problem of misery and why do we suffer and all these things and it's very poetic to read you know makes you go back and read the biblical book of job
如果书里有一首诗什么的，他们就开始翻白眼。我认为这就是卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）在医学机构之外的原因，而且可能永远都会是。学校里说的是什么？你不能成为荣格派，因为没有办法客观地反驳它，这个理论。这个理论无效，因为没有办法客观地反驳它。就像没有办法反驳一个隐喻一样，它不是一种字面上的心理学，它是……是的，它不是那样建立的，你知道。他的书《对约伯的回答》（Answer to Job）是……我一直觉得是一首了不起的诗，真的。你理解《对约伯的回答》，它非常好，它是关于苦难的问题，为什么我们受苦，所有这些事情，读起来非常有诗意，你知道，让你回去读圣经中的《约伯记》
and get some new insights out but it tells you about the awareness that derives from suffering and that suffering is an important element in navigating one's way through life that suffering generates values last line of the red book is thank you for the suffering oh I guess I am plagiarized in the suffering generates values I may be wrong there that's my memory but yeah so I find I just find that really interesting that you know uh to look at things that way and and what is tragedy tragedy tragedy is a finger-wagging form of uh of wisdom isn't it what is tragic what is tragic is meaningful i always tell people that
并获得一些新的见解。但它告诉你关于从苦难中产生的意识，以及苦难是导航人生道路的一个重要因素，苦难产生价值。《红书》的最后一行是“感谢苦难”。哦，我想我剽窃了“苦难产生价值”。我可能错了，那是我的记忆，但是的，所以我发现……我只是觉得这真的很有趣，你知道，以那种方式看待事物，什么是悲剧？悲剧，悲剧是一种指责式的智慧形式，不是吗？什么是悲剧？什么是悲剧是有意义的。我总是告诉人们这一点。
what is truly tragic is always meaningful that sounds like simone vey you read simone vey or any of the myths of course but they got the publisher perfect they they they did the publisher did all this republishing of a bunch of um greek plays and um they would have like historical photographs on the different things. Like for the Agamemnon, it's like Mussolini going into Italy and different things. And, but the, for the Antigone,
真正悲剧的东西总是有意义的，这听起来像是西蒙娜·薇依的话。你读过西蒙娜·薇依或者任何神话吗？当然读过，但出版商做得太完美了，他们重新出版了一堆希腊戏剧，而且在不同的书里配上了历史照片。比如《阿伽门农》，配的是墨索里尼进入意大利的照片等等。但是，对于《安提戈涅》，
there was just a picture of Simone Bay. Like, I was like, I mean, that's just a perfect thing. Cause there's such a melancholy sadness that you get this person who is so wise, but it's also kind of halfway in this world and halfway out.
上面只有一张西蒙娜·薇依的照片。我当时就觉得，这真是太完美了。因为那种忧郁的悲伤感，让你觉得这个人如此睿智，却又仿佛一半身处这个世界，一半游离于世外。
Oh yeah. One of my, one of my worst puns of all time, I must say is, uh, that you get this person who is so wise but is also kind of halfway in this world and halfway out. Oh, yeah. One of my worst puns of all time, though, I must say is, Euripides, believe it or not. You've heard of Ripley's, believe it or not, but I always say, Euripides, believe it or not.
哦，是的。我必须得说，我这辈子最烂的双关语之一，就是关于欧里庇得斯（Euripides）的。你听说过《信不信由你》（Ripley's Believe It or Not）吧？但我总是说“欧里庇得斯，信不信由你”（Euripides, believe it or not）。
That's clever. Oh, yeah. Some people find that tiresome, but it's fine. Well, I'm going to cut us off in a minute here. We can keep going for a few minutes yet. Yeah, you've got a meeting coming up, so I don't want to keep you past that. But this is more fun. Yeah.
那很聪明。哦，是的。有些人觉得这很烦人，但没关系。好吧，我一会儿得打断我们一下。我们还可以再聊几分钟。是的，你马上有个会议，所以我不想耽误你。但这更有趣。
Well, it's fascinating. We'd love to do a part two or something. Maybe we could do just kind of a poetry reading or something. Another thing too is if you're ever in Texas, you can drink some of my wine with me. Oh yeah, that'd be wonderful. We do some work with another clinic down there and we're thinking they have a thing here. So I might, maybe, maybe at some point, I don't know. One of my good friends is from there, but I don't travel a ton after the kids and pretty much just work and do stuff for my kids.
嗯，这太迷人了。我们很乐意做第二部分之类的。也许我们可以做个诗歌朗诵什么的。还有一件事，如果你去德克萨斯州，可以和我一起喝点我的酒。哦，那太棒了。我们在那边和另一家诊所合作，我们正在考虑他们这里有个项目。所以也许，在某个时候，我不知道。我的一个好朋友是那里人，但我有了孩子之后就不怎么旅行了，基本上就是工作和照顾孩子。
Listen, you have a wonderful day and it's been a joy to talk to you, sir. Yeah. Thank you so much. I really appreciate it. Let me, um, stop the recording. And then is there anything else that you want to plug that you want to talk about? People can get your books or the books still for sale on Amazon? They sure are. So parallel myths and living myths by Robert, by, uh, Jeff Berlin, anything else? People can get your books. Are the books still for sale on Amazon? They sure are. So Parallel Myths and Living Myths by J.F. Barilane. Anything else? I think it's by Robert Frost. I don't know why Robert wasn't there. I swear I never drink whiskey and use a gun, so I don't think you're worried.
听着，祝你今天过得愉快，能和你交谈真是太高兴了，先生。是的。非常感谢。让我，嗯，停止录音。还有什么你想宣传或想谈论的吗？人们可以买到你的书吗？书还在亚马逊上卖吗？当然还在卖。所以《平行神话》和《活的神话》，作者是杰夫·贝尔莱恩，还有别的吗？人们可以买到你的书。书还在亚马逊上卖吗？当然还在卖。所以《平行神话》和《活的神话》，作者是J.F.贝尔莱恩。还有别的吗？我想是罗伯特·弗罗斯特写的。我不知道为什么罗伯特不在那儿。我发誓我从不喝威士忌玩枪，所以我想你不必担心。
Let's see. All right. So those books are on Amazon and then jfbearlane.com. That's J-F-B-I-E-R-L-E-I-N.com. And we'll link to that in the show notes and the notes on the YouTube, but check it out. And thank you so much for making time to sit with us. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
让我们看看。好的。所以这些书在亚马逊上，还有jfbearlane.com。那是J-F-B-I-E-R-L-E-I-N.com。我们会在节目笔记和YouTube的笔记中提供链接，请去看看。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们坐下来交谈。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。